but there are aspects to all of us that
if they were exposed to the harsh
unsympathetic critic would result in
severe humiliation and mercury from
close up we are none of us reliably
impressive we get agitated fretful
cantankerous and panicky under the
pressure of events we shout slam doors
and let out screams or wails we have
episodes of absurd clumsiness we bump
into doors trip and drop things down our
front
we're worried pretty much all the time
about how others see us about where our
careers are going and about everything
important that we've forgotten to do in
our lives we long for love but our
unthinking and insensitive
around those close to us we are ghosts
in our efforts to seduce and pitiful in
our requests for attention our bodies
have a range of shameful habits and
vulnerabilities we are from certain
angles truly embarrassing propositions
all this we struggle to hide the inner
idiot is carefully monitored and
ruthlessly gagged we have learned from
our earliest years that the only
priority around vulnerability is to
disguise it completely we strive
remorselessly to look composed to erase
the evidence of our silliness and to try
to appear a great deal more normal than
we know we are we are understandably
very focused on the downsides of
vulnerability
what is far less well recognized is
vulnerabilities occasional very
significant and profound upsides there
are moments when the revelation of
weakness far from being a catastrophe is
the only possible route to connection
and respect at points we made there to
explain with rare frankness that we are
afraid that we are sometimes bad and
that we have done many silly things
and rather than appalling our companions
these revelations may serve to endear s
to them humanizing us in their eyes and
letting them feel that their own
vulnerabilities have echoes in the lives
of others together we realize that the
definition of what is normal has missed
out on key aspects of our mutual re
in other words the vulnerability can be
a bedrock of friendship friendship
properly understood not just or
primarily as a process of admiration but
as an exchange of sympathy and
consolation for the Troublesome business
of being alive there can of course be
unfortunate ways of handling
vulnerability when we do so in the form
of an aggressive demand that others
rescue us or when our frailties lack of
boundaries or when we're close to rage
in hysteria rather than melancholy or
grief good vulnerability doesn't expect
another person to solve all our
difficulties we let them see a tricky
part of who we are simply in the hope
that they will be Bolden to feel more at
ease with their own less dignified sighs
good vulnerability is fundamentally
generous it takes the first step of
disclosure so as to render it safe for
others to unburden themselves and
disclose something of their hidden
selves in turn it's a gift in the form
of a risk taken for somebody else
furthermore displays of vulnerability
have a curious way of signaling that we
are despite the embarrassing of owls far
from fundamentally ridiculous or pitiful
we are rather strong enough to be weak
to let our silliness our idiocy our
anger and our sadness show confident
that these do not have to be the final
verdicts on who we are we proceed with a
bold sense that despite the lack of
surface evidence everyone is in the end
has wounded aggrieved worried and
damaged as we are and that we're not
therefore through our disclosures
casting ourselves out of the Klan for
good
we are simply reconfirming our essential
membership of the human race it's
something of a minor tragedy that we
should spend so much of our lives
striving to hide our weakness when it is
in fact only upon the dignified sharing
of vulnerability that true friendship
and love can arise we love bringing you
these films if you want to help us to
keep bringing you thoughtful content
please consider supporting us by
visiting our shop at the link on your
screen
now